RAISED THE COMPENSATION YOUR
EMPLOYEES.
>> Sean: LET’S GET AMERICANS
BACK TO WORK SAFELY, BREAKING
TONIGHT THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR
OF MICHIGAN IS IN HOT WATER
AFTER BEING CAUGHT HIRING
DEMOCRATIC LINKED FIRMS TO LEAD
EFFORTS TO TRACK THE SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS AND COLLECT HEALTH
DATA, HERE’S A REACTION TO ALL
OF THIS --
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, YOU’RE THE ONE WHO
POINTED OUT YOU CAN’T PAY PEOPLE
MORE MONEY TO STAY AT HOME.
TO THE CREDIT OF THE
PENNSYLVANIA PEOPLE, THEY ARE
FIGHTING TO GO BACK TO WORK,
SAFELY, YOU GOT TO DO IT SAFELY.
>> LET ME PUT THIS IN CONTEXT.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF YOU
LOSE YOUR JOB, IF YOU ARE
FURLOUGHED, YOU YOU’RE LAID OFF
BECAUSE OF MITIGATION, YOU’VE
DONE NOTHING WRONG, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU RECEIVE 100% OF
YOUR PAY BUT WHAT WE DON’T WANT
TO DO -- UNEMPLOYMENT IS TO PAY
YOU MORE THAN YOU ACTUALLY
RECEIVE WHEN YOU WERE WORKING.
CONTRARY TO WHAT THE
PENNSYLVANIA GOVERNOR SAYS, IT
IS NOT GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY TO
PAY PEOPLE MORE NOT TO WORK THAN
ACTUALLY WORK AND THAT’S WHAT
WE’RE DOING.
THIS IS BECOMING A MAGNET TO
DRAW PEOPLE OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE, WE WILL NEVER HAVE AN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY UNTIL WE FIX
THIS.
YOU SHOULD GET 100% OF YOUR
WAGES UP TO $50,000 BUT YOU
SHOULD NEVER BE PAID MORE IN
UNEMPLOYMENT THAN YOUR EMPLOYER
PAYS YOU, THAT SKEWS THE WHOLE
ECONOMY AND THIS GUY IN
PENNSYLVANIA DOESN’T GET THAT, I
BET YOU A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
PENNSYLVANIA DO.
I WANT TO ASK HIM, DO YOU AGREE
WITH AOC THAT WE SHOULD BE
EXCITED ABOUT THE DESTRUCTION OF
THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY?
THAT’S THE PENNSYLVANIA GOVERNOR
WHO HAS A REAL OIL AND GAS
SUPPLY THEY ARE SITTING ON TOP
OF, DO YOU AGREE WITH HER?
ASK JOE BIDEN, DO YOU AGREE WITH
AOC THAT WE SHOULD BE HAPPY TO
DESTROY THE OIL AND GAS BUSINESS
IN AMERICA?
>> Sean: I THINK IT’S A GREAT
QUESTION.
TOMORROW, WE ARE GOING TO
COMPARE THE RESPONSE OF FLORIDA
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS WITH THE
MICHIGAN GOVERNOR, SHE HASN’T
BEEN DOING SO WELL.
RON DeSANTIS DID A LOT OF
THINGS RIGHT THAT HE HASN’T
GOTTEN CREDIT FOR.
SHE JUST AWARDED A CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE CONTRACT TO A FIRM
THAT --
>> YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS STUFF UP.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THE DESIRE
TO DESTROY DONALD TRUMP BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS GREATER THAN
IT IS TO DESTROY THE VIRUS.
IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY, THEY
WERE IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT,
NANCY PELOSI SAID FOR ALMOST A
MONTH, THE TRIAL DIDN’T END,
CHUCK SCHUMER WOULD’VE HAD
WITNESSES ALL THROUGH FEBRUARY.
MY DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES HERE
HAVE LOST THEIR WAY.
ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR OF PENNSYLVANIA, YOU’RE
WRONG, MY FRIEND WHEN YOU SAY
IT’S GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY TO PAY
PEOPLE MORE TO BE UNEMPLOYED
THAN TO ACTUALLY WORK.
THAT’S NOT GOOD ECONOMICS AND
MOST AMERICANS ARE NOT LOOKING
FOR A PAY RAISE IN UNEMPLOYMENT,
THEY WOULD LIKE TO GET THEIR JOB
BACK AT.
>> Sean: THEY WOULD LIKE TO
GET THEIR JOB BACK, THERE’S
NEVER BEEN A MEDICAL
MOBILIZATION THAT HAS BEEN THIS
FAST AND IN THE END, WE BELIEVE
EVERY LIFE MATTERS.
IF WE WANT TO CURE CANCER AND
HEART DISEASE TOO.
NEVER AGAIN, I WANT THE
QUESTIONS ASKED OF EVERY
DEMOCRAT RUNNING FOR CONGRESS,
EVERY ONE OF THE MEDIA TO
ANSWER, DID THE PRESIDENT MAKE
THE RIGHT CALL AS IT RELATES TO
THE TRAVEL BAN TEN DAYS AFTER
THE FIRST KNOWN CASE IN THE U.S.
DID THE PRESIDENT TO A GOOD JOB
BUILDING 25,000 HOSPITAL BEDS,
MOBILIZING AND PROVIDING THE
PERSONNEL, MOBILIZING THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO BUILD
VENTILATORS AND ALL THE SHIELDS
AND MASKS AND RESPIRATORS AND
GOWNS AND GLOVES, DID HE DO
ANYTHING GOOD TO?
ACCORDING TO THEM, HE DIDN’T.
EVEN DR. FELT SHE WAS SAYING THE
RISK WAS LOW ON FEBRUARY 29TH.
CHINA SCREWED EVERYBODY HERE.
>> CHINA IS THE BAD GUY BUT I
WANT YOU TO ASK THE LEFT, DO YOU
AGREE THAT THE CDC GUIDELINES
IMPLEMENTED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP
ON MARCH 13TH SAVED MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS FROM A TERRIBLE DEATH?
DO YOU AGREE DECLARING A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY ON
MARCH 13TH, MOBILIZED THIS
COUNTRY TO SAVE LIVES?
DO YOU AGREE THAT INVOKING THE
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT HELPS THE
MEDICAL SUPPLY CHAIN GOT TO
BRING BACK FROM CHINA.
ON FEBRUARY 29TH, HERE’S WHAT
DR. FAUCI SAID ON THE DENTE
SHOW.
HE NEED TO PUT THIS IN YOUR LIST
OF QUOTES.
SATURDAY MORNING IN AMERICA,
PEOPLE WERE WAKING UP WITH REAL
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS, THEY WANT
TO GO TO THE MALLS, TO MOVIES,
MAYBE TO THE GYM AS WELL.
SHOULD WE BE CHANGING OUR
HABITS, AND IF SO, HOW?
KNOW, RIGHT NOW AT THIS MOMENT
THERE IS NO NEED TO CHANGE
ANYTHING YOU’RE DOING ON A
DAY-TO-DAY BASIS, RIGHT NOW THE
RISK IS STILL LOW BUT THIS COULD
CHANGE.
THAT’S ON FEBRUARY 29TH, THE
SMARTEST GUY IN AMERICA, I TRUST
HIM.
HIS BEST ADVICE ON
FEBRUARY 29TH, IT’S OKAY TO GO
TO THE GYM, OKAY TO GO TO THE
MOVIES, IT’S OKAY TO GO TO THE
MALL.
STOP BLAMING TRUMP, THAT’S WHAT
BOW SHE THOUGHT ON FEBRUARY 29TH
AND BY MARCH 13TH, THINGS DID
CHANGE.
THE PRESIDENT ACTED.
>> Sean: THIS GUY HAS SAVED
LIVES THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER,
HE’S BEEN A HERO, WERE NOT